federal investigators are looking into
the cause of multiple gas explosions
that erupted in three Massachusetts
towns north of Boston hurricane
Florence's and the blast left dozens of
homes and other buildings demolished or
engulfed in flames one person was killed
and the state's governor says 10 others
were injured crews responded to 70
reports of fires explosions and gas
leaks across Lawrence Andover and North
Andover
Kenneth Craig is in Lawrence where fire
crews have been working throughout the
night
Kenneth good morning well good morning
to you John one of those homes that
exploded is actually right down the
street behind me but to be honest with
you we are being kept pretty far back
because police told me this morning many
of these homes many of these areas are
still being considered active crime
scenes the Andover fire chief described
the scene out here as something like
Armageddon noting that as soon as crews
put out one fire another one would pop
up in the building right next door
flames engulfed more than 60 structures
on Thursday prompting evacuations of
entire neighborhoods and widespread
confusion on roads 18-year old Lionel
Robinson was inside a car right down the
street from where I'm standing when a
chimney from a house explosion fell on
his vehicle he died at the hospital a
few hours later emergency management
officials believe over pressurized gas
lines triggered the fires but
investigators have yet to reveal an
official cause prior to these explosions
the Columbia Gas Company said it would
be upgrading gas lines and neighborhoods
across the state including where the
explosions occurred officials have cut
power to these neighborhoods and they've
shut down the gas lines indefinitely the
Massachusetts governor Charlie Baker
says it could be weeks or even months
kale before we know an official cause of
how this all happened all right can I
thank you very much it looks like a
movie scene when we look at the fire and
then all the police cars behind you
thank you very much for joining us today